okay all right let me start over
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember them all right this movie is
not only bad it is annoying ungodly
annoying just we think it needs to take
a break from big annoys my kitchen
tomorrow 9:00 okay get the title of away
the magic voice
wait till you hear this this is a
children story about Christopher
Columbus as told by German filmmakers
yeah that's right
German filmmakers that's the equivalent
of American filmmakers making in
children's film about Russian history
look how fucking well that turned out
shit we came and get our own history
right so what makes you think that
Germans have a shot but this goes beyond
just magical powers a talking bad or a
talking tree no no this story goes right
off the deep end of the flat friggin
earth what makes this film especially
horrendous oh you'll see in a moment
let's dive right into the magic void so
is the credits roll we see that the film
is too cheap to get opening animation so
they just throw their storyboards at us
we see the narrator starts to talk about
the story we're about to see and yeah
tell me if the voice sounds familiar
a long time ago people thought the world
was flat and if you sailed unchartered
waters you just might fall over the edge
into space that's right it's our very
own Mickey Rooney one of the biggest
star in the world
studied Elizabeth Taylor the other
former biggest star in the world a
trainer of Care Bears yeah to play
Hawaii would be sometime actually it is
eerie how exactly the same his
performances from both these kids movies
II listen
but in 1492 there appeared an Italian
navigator a man with a revolutionary
idea he thought the world was square and
his name was the Care Bears bill that
smile as long as I don't to see him I'm
okay here we go
we then see our main hero of the movie
yeah I bet you thought it was gonna be
Christopher Columbus didn't you he does
only take up two thirds of the fucking
poster but no it's a little wood worm
named Pico played by not former biggest
star in the world Corey Feldman I used
to be a bookworm i sat up on the show I
read a Matt exam okay I'll say yes the
singer can sing the song writer can't
write and this has nothing to do a
Christopher collapse
yeah but he does eventually come across
Christopher Columbus voiced by Oh
dum-dum why did you have to make so many
bad movies do you think I like
continually making fun of you you seem
like a nice guy I liked you you were
really cool but yeah it's the story of
America told by Germans you should know
better dumb you should know better but
on the bright side he is Italian so he
can probably do an authentic Italian
accent my map is show stinker or maybe
he'll be as authentic as Mario hey at
least they're aiming for the popular
stereotypes hey I think I like to show
you something
I think you're gonna like a lot dude
it's me Christopher Columbus its 1492
and the world she's still a flat head
maybe it's not so important that's
important are you kidding
she's uh she's around course a drowned
blockhead what do you think uh no
disrespect to insects but how the fuck
does a woman worm know the world is
round
I mean seriously where do they come from
or what worms just the smartest
creatures on the planet I'm at the
thinking to wear B flat but well it's
not it's round where I'm at the thinking
that Christianity is the true religion
no it isn't it's Rastafarian but more
yes we're I'm a good thinkin that we're
totally alone in space no we're not
there's the Bardo nians once the blood
Oni and government gets enough money to
fund their space program
they'll come to earth and enslave us all
who all where I'm at the peak in this
movie's gonna be a big hit that have a
drink so have you noticed the main
problem with this movie I mean outside
of the horrible characters voice-acting
story and animation it's a little hard
to get through and edited clips but
let's see if you can figure it out in
this clip
excuse me do you mind
I suppose you wondering what I got here
you know I couldn't really care less no
how about this one my brand-new tea
which will make you great to beyond your
wildest dreams that sell oh yeah and
what makes you think I'm not already
great beyond my wildest dreams no no you
still not getting it
let's try one more AHA are you going
away Chinese just got here yes I believe
it never shuts up there is always
talking always love music only sonic not
dating your ears the whole movie is like
this there is never a silent moment
where the film can just breathe or take
a break it is nothing but noise
if there's one thing I can't stand it's
all that guy live nice nice it's like
it's afraid if it stops being loud and
bouncy it's going to lose the children's
attention and that's not a good thing
children need slow moments they need
pauses it teaches them patience and the
appreciation of atmosphere this this is
just winging your keys in front of their
dumb little faces for an hour and a half
shut up shut up shut up
Thank You Arnold so let's try to
continue this review despite all that
nice nice job shut up thank you
he goes to the king and queen to tell
them his idea I'm sorry the word worms
idea and they seem to be unborn mostly
because the Queen has the hots for
Columbus interesting interpretation but
no one dear just another genius I don't
believe you he's much too handsome and
apparently he's a mind reader too
because he knew exactly what she was
gonna say there what disgusting display
but don't let it get to you sire by the
way you see this guy in the bag here who
looks like a mix between fake and then
too far the shady fella always telling
the King not to trust Columbus yeah he
never shows up again not once in the
rest of the movie he was all hope you
see total list of the animation Oh
these are pretty cool so Pico goes into
one of the other rooms and finds a
Firefly named Marilyn princess of the
Moon sprites again we never see the king
or queen so we'll just assume she's a
responsibility tucking or I was in the
land of blue blue Twilight where the
nectar is always sweet happy and free
and then from a land far away and in sit
down when there is a lord some that last
princess the secret of your magic light
will be mine yeah remember this from the
history books magic light insect armies
Lord swarm me this is the history of how
the Smurfs discovered America but can we
hear that damn story about Christopher
Columbus it's this one it comes back I'm
not scared of nobody
yes come on so people tries to get her
out of the chandelier which seems like a
pretty lame prison as she could fly at
any point what's a mother bug see her
and tried to stop her from escaping
Wow laziest fight she'd ever they're
just holding her and he starts laughing
call James Cameron we have a contender
for best action scene it's this form
Lord where you will be by Tristan
merrily I keep so the swarm war takes
her back to his land fits the question
why did he bring her there to begin with
and pk vows to find her I'll find you
all the way across the ocean and you'll
never guess where the swarm Lords land
happens to be that's right America what
are the odds
so what Columbus happens to be getting
ready to go to America Pico is asleep
yeah
I'll find you Marilyn all the way across
the ocean right after a teeny-weeny
little power nap don't want to be groggy
lumbus wait don't leave me
so what's the ship sets sail Columbus
suddenly realizes he forgot something
how could I forget about Pico go sure my
little woodworker friend
before he's the one who told me the
world was around
Oh ping Comanche is to get a ride on a
bird and ends up planning a board I
taught that maybe you got left behind
well I met this beautiful girl sir I
really like her a lot she was taken away
when the evil swarm woods is kingdom of
the West but do we go to the west to get
to the east so we could look for your
love under the one I love how so
accepting he is that there's just a
swarm war that kidnaps a princess and
they're gonna go find him now but hey if
I was talking to a wood worm with a
voice of Donatello from the teenage
mutant fucking Ninja Turtles I guess I
believed anything - man what's he doing
he's talking to his little worm
get out everybody
no no he's kissing's a little world uh
the stuff they're getting away with on
kids shows these days so while the crew
thinks he's crazy I can't imagine why
Columbus has a relatively pointless
dream about finding the New World
oh wait a minute what the hell did he
just pull a spyglass out of his gonads
he just pulled that spyglass out of his
lots part of that how did that ever get
past German censorship
don't they have any shame on you Aang
it's only for a second but it's just so
troubling Lee confusing I mean what the
hell do you call that the Wunder boner
my wife would like that hey forget I
mention it so so this movie couldn't
possibly be any more batshit crazy we
get this insane dream sequence it's sort
of like watching pink elephants from
Dumbo while someone was oh I don't know
pulling a spyglass out of your dick
what'll I do why don't I do what an
unusual view ah yes
the dream so yeah after that incredibly
important scene we cut to the next night
where seems like the crew still thinks
Colombians is crazy simply because he
talks to a woodworm and says a Firefly
princess needs rescuing and they tried
to do him in but he sits a song on an
accordion and that seems to make
everything okay
for life this season like falafel and Oh
me well I guess this is a clear sign
that their captain isn't totally insane
me I think he's about as valid as
captain fucking kangaroo
but hey difference drugs different folks
so because we see how much depth and
texture the last dream sequence gave
think if once a picot as well and is it
me or is most of the dubbing in this
movie very similar to a Popeye cartoon
watch Marilyn thank me this is great
opening above the earth with the girl of
my dreams
yeah just gonna be picking me some full
is gonna mean the ball is moving little
Zealand I know that pretty lady let's
come together come together okay I
really like Jamie because I can fly oh
my hand you know it's not even really
dialogue anymore it's just naming things
that they see I love space Oh trees Oh
box office on Emil I'm learning so much
about my character from this on to once
again the crew gets fed up with waiting
for dry land and they try to hear some
more kid-friendly imagery folks we got
characters being hanged and penis
friendly spy glasses
you know for kids wouldn't you know what
they just happened to hit dry land while
Columbus was hey so it seems they
finally reached America and what the
hell
Magic Island Joe cars we all remember
the giant Aztec temple in America that
was run by the swarm Lord of kidnapped
the princess of blue Twilight so he can
figure out the power of her magic light
it's just common knowledge
show me fucking shoot me so they meet up
with a talking beaver okay who shows
them the way to the temple
Columbus wants to go there so he can
bring back gold and diamonds to his
Queen but I don't know if that temple
has any gold or diamond no no the
diamonds are here so it turns out
Maryland is in the temple on top of a
large honeycomb
ah this we've never seen any bees in
this warm and they try to defeat the bad
guy in rescuer and now mr. puppet will
you get the gold
I can't even touch that scene you have a
hand puppet caught fire
what would you say hey come on
why didn't you go with him at first he
said come on and she just saw a stood
there was she do busy giggling time is
of the essence bitch come on ready this
place is gonna blow
so the beaver eats through the honeycomb
that almost sounds like an innuendo but
I'm not clever enough and the whole
temple somehow comes crackling down
because of that
so Pecola Marilyn get back together and
we see the natives of this land
oh oh Fez oughta be rich you stolen our
Lyle destroyed our sacred to us but I've
made squishy with the swarm how can we
ever thank you
that's right the Native Americans were
honoring the swarm Lord all this time
and made a giant Aztec temple to honor
him what did you think they lived in
teepees or something you're a fuckin
dumbass that map I made squishy with a
swarm how can we ever thank you the lab
hand it over we not only discovered the
new world but you were right the world
she's around
just think Pico because of you and me
one day there's gonna be a big bigger
city right here and there's gonna be a
lot of people told buildings maybe
they're gonna name something after us
who knows Columbus Circle sounds good to
me
oh and don't forget about the dis
muttering lots and lots of other
dismantling the tour to look up for the
chi rating in the next one fall kids are
gonna be a bloodbath
so that was awful what else can you
really say about the dumping sounds like
it was done in one go the history is
beyond insulting the characters are
horseshit even the animation is
inconsistent sometimes it almost looks
like something from Disney but then
other times it looks like a half a
Saturday morning cartoon and of course
it never fucking shuts up
all I gotta say germy is that if this is
what you think American history was like
Bugs Bunny was more authentic than yo
and what's up for Daksha indeed Germany
what the fuck is up I'm the Nostalgia
Critic and Lala Lala Lala Lala
oh the life as I see is the life for me
no dumb as a lender be
we love it this planet delighted divided
what other life already
ba yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah